Nói lời chuyến thăm chính thức lần thứ 2 của sâm đách thì pada hôn mà nè đến Việt Nam trên kương vị thủ tướng
vương quân khó cảm buổi chia. Qua đó, cạo động lực mới thúc đại quan hệ hai nước thức tục đi
và chiều sau thức chất và hiểu quả. Vất phần tạo giữ môi trường hà bên của định trong khu vật.
Nóng có thứ thực trong việc xây dựng cộ đồng á siêan. Chênh tảng quan hệ hiểu nghĩ
phát triển tốt đẹp. Chuyến thăm chính thức Việt Nam và thăm dự diễn đàn thương lai á siêan của thủ tướng
cộng thân kia, khói nghĩa quan trọng tạo động lực mới cho quan hệ hai nước tiếp tục đi và chờ sau thức chất và hiểu quả trên mỗi lịch vật.
Nhat là khi hai nước đang chuẩn bị kiểm sống miter năm, phát quan hệ ngoại giao Việt Nam càng buì chia,
hà mi tư thằng sáu năm mùnh in chính chăm xáu bài, hà mi tư thằng xáu năm hà nghỉ khủ trăm hái bài.
Mùi trọng đường có ý nghĩa đặc biệt trong liệt sửa quan hệ xong phương.
Sau lấy đóan 2 tuyến dẫn đầu đà bị rượu cấp cao hai nước diễn hệ hệ ngoại đam.
Nhà mẹng giá khi khoảng hục tác giá hãy nước thời gian về qua và để xuất các thường vướng hợp tác thời gian tới và chừng kiến lễ chào văn kiện hợp tác giữa Việt Nam, các buồn chia.